[Music]
thank you
all right so we are we are locked and
loaded and ready to go so this is
intended to be fun it's an experimental
format it will get in front of
interesting people
so let's just have a good time with it
and
if we need to Zig and zag as the format
settles will zig and zag okay with that
Kevin do you wanna yeah
take a deep breath and lead us in
there's lots of definitions for heresy
but one that I like to use and ask
people about is
what's something that you believe
that the people that you most admire
don't believe it might even find
shocking
and to be a true heresy in this sense it
has to be something that's not just
necessarily an unpopular idea
but it's an unpopular idea among the
people that you hang out with in your
circle
the people that you most respect for and
we're not right now going to try and
uncover some heresies and they should be
in some senses things that you think
the rest of us here the other four of us
probably don't believe and might also
find hard to believe
and then
we'll kind of go through and see if we
can maybe change some people's minds and
see if
there's a way in which we can kind of
understand it and the whole purpose I
think of this exercise is in some ways
is to
cultivate
independent thinking because
if you have a heresy of in this
definition that means you kind of
arrived at it on your own it wasn't
something that you inherited because
you inherit the things around you it
would be things that you absorbed things
that you didn't really think about
so in order to arrive at something that
the people around you also find weird
odd or hard to believe you've you've
probably had to arrive at it on your own
so we're trying to cultivate that skill
and celebrate that skill of
trying to have some sense of independent
thinking and not necessarily just
interrogating or absorbing the ideas and
so
one of the things that we'll first do
with with it is I found in doing this
numbers of times that it's good to kind
of try to help collectively refine the
actual statement of the heresy to put it
in a form that makes it easy to to see
it's
orthogonal relationship with everything
else that we believe so what I like to
do is to go around and each one of us
can present a heresy that they
believe and then we'll examine it and
see if we can understand it first and
then see where it sits into our own
beliefs so
we're just an experiment as Tim says and
we don't know where this is going to go
we've done this in small groups that
like dinners
this is a public version of it we'll see
what happens so
we don't have an order in mind but
Josh would you like to suggest a heresy
that you think the rest of us would have
trouble believing
happy to do it although I have to say
going first is no great gift but thank
you Kevin I I feel like part of the
heresies probably should be disagreeing
with part of what the premise and I just
have to say this premise the premise of
the heresies the definition so you know
you said that the people you most admire
would disagree with you I'm going to
talk about something where I would say
the person I admire most with whom I'm
closest my wife has persuaded me that
it's something I now believe that I did
not believe but consistent with your
point of view that many people probably
don't think so that's the following okay
so do you think that the rest of us
would we'll also find this heretical I
don't know only one way to find out I'm
gonna try it out on you but you suspect
that well I suspect it's definitely a
radical relative to the teaching and
training that most of you got during
your educations now whether you've
overcome that education in ways that
might make you open to this idea that I
don't know because I don't know you I'm
hopeful that it will be at least
stimulating and interesting I'm eager to
get invited back so if it's a disaster I
will have failed okay that's a great
setup okay so what's there let me start
with a little hypothetical you know you
have a friend who comes back from a date
and how many times have you heard her
say the date was a disaster the guy I
was out with he just listened too
carefully or how many times have you
heard about a couple that are breaking
up and you know say why did those guys
break up
and your friend says well the couple
broke up because they just listened to
each other too carefully my hypothesis
is you've never heard either those
statements we've all had friends who
come back from a date and said that guy
just would not stop talking or you've
heard about couples and all they did for
many many years was argue with each
other
and why is that well at least one reason
I think is that we spend a
disproportionate amount of time doing
all of our educational lives being
taught two things we get taught how to
speak publicly and we get taught how to
debate and yet if you think about what
forms the core or most meaningful
relationships it's the ability to listen
and we somehow have this notion that
listening is an inherited skill that
someone's intuitively a good listener or
not so my heretical ideas we need to
de-emphasize and stop spending so much
time teaching people how to debate and
spend a lot more time teaching people
how to listen
well that's predicated on the idea that
talking isn't listening well I would
definitely say talking is not listening
and listening is not waiting to talk so
I think many people think that the
premise of listening is just waiting
your turn
and I think part of the argument I'd
like to make is that there are lots of
teachable skills around listening which
make people better able to understand
differences demonstrate empathy and have
the capacity actually to learn in ways
that just teaching debating does not I
find myself in total agreement so I've
failed so let me hop in for a second I
want you to it sounds like potentially
pushback I would say though it is on
topic in the sense that
in our back and forth about this episode
The Point has come up
strongly that speaking heresies is one
thing but developing the ability to
listen to heresies is also important so
it is sort of compatible in a sense
which maybe means it doesn't fit into
the the heretical bucket but how do you
feel Kevin a total agreement I think
listening is the superpower I just did
this book of advice and that was one of
the the main topics was that active
listening which is an important I would
say caveat that is an active listening
rather than just a passive listening
that is the superpower
yeah so
others Noah
did you have any comments about this
heresy yeah I mean I think it's an
interesting form of a heresy and I think
it is a heresy because it's a heresy
that it's hard to disagree with without
sounding like an [__]
can I say that word on your podcast Tim
yeah you can absolutely I'm from Long
Island you can say whatever you want
there you go so when someone says yeah
we really need to learn to listen more
you know and I'm sure every person in my
life would agree that what Josh said is
exactly what I need to hear
but I do kind of have an instinct to
want to say
yeah no you can't really teach somebody
to listen well
you know you could teach some passive
listening by making them spit back what
they've heard but we all agree that
that's not that useful a skill
you can teach them tricks like I will
mirror back to you what you've said so
that you have the experience of feeling
properly listened to and we probably all
at least those of us of a certain age
have you know gotten some training in
that whether we liked it or not maybe
from a romantic partner
but even that's not really listening I
mean really listening requires being
genuinely open to the other person's
experience and when you just at a deep
level
just don't think their experience
matches reality or you think that their
opinion is just so flat out wrong sure
you can teach yourself to listen to get
inside their head to convince them that
they're wrong and sure you can learn to
listen because it's a really useful tool
to get ahead in life but I don't I think
the heresy if I hear it right Josh is
not for those reasons you know not
instrumental listening to get something
but there's inherent deep value in
listening to other people and I think
that's probably true but I'm not sure
you can really train people to do that
it's like training people and being
open-minded I mean maybe you can do it
but it seems very very difficult to
figure out how just to jump in for a sec
Noah
I think you were making two different
points one is whether in fact
it's possible to teach something like
listening in a way that won't come
across the superficial that was the
first point about mirroring
we'll come back to that the second point
I think you were making was that in fact
just listening actually is an
understanding and understanding is
different from listening those are the
two points you were making
yeah I think so and the third maybe is
that really listening might be something
that you can't teach that you just have
to like make your way through life and
get experience but they're formally
teaching it wouldn't wouldn't do us much
good but now ask yourself Noah your
reaction
to what I put back to you where I was
demonstrating that I actually had heard
you and that I was paying attention to
what you said as opposed to what might
have been my natural inclination to say
Noah you're a law professor you're used
to lecturing people the fact that you
may have the incapacity to listen
probably doesn't mean this is a bad idea
that would be an alternative response
and probably somewhat less productive
but if I was debating you no I think
it's way better
and so I think what I'm getting at is
first of all on your two points I don't
think I agree with the first one the
fact that something might seem
superficial when you first try it
doesn't mean that it can't permeate in a
way that will fundamentally change your
behavior so picking up on Kevin's point
one of the skills of active listening
certainly is mirroring but that as you
said a relatively superficial tool when
it's first practiced your second point
about the difference between listening
and understanding I think is more
complicated and harder but the process
of doing that does teach one empathy you
know the line I like which I think is
very helpful is curious not Furious if
your first reaction to hearing someone
even to your point someone with whom you
disagree quite profoundly is to be
furious it's very unlikely you're ever
going to get to a point of empathy or
the ability to understand what she might
think
if you're curious in the other hand if
you go through a process of asking
questions I think that is a skill that
ultimately will allow you to actually
develop some empathy to develop some
understanding even with people with whom
you disagree quite profoundly
I wanted to ask no the third point just
to clarify so I understood when you said
that you didn't think we'll call this
maybe a sophisticated level of listening
as something that isn't teachable do you
mean that a person could not improve
their ability to do it or just that when
you say teaching or do you mean like in
an educational formal context or do you
are you saying that they can't actually
improve it definitely people can get
better at listening okay and
they can also get better at
understanding over time sure
you can also train yourself to Greater
empathy I suspect I think Josh is right
about that too what I'm thinking about
is what most education looks like where
we say okay now we're going to start
training people in listening
some kind of a formal process where you
try to make people listen I mean look as
Josh pointed out I teach constitutional
law for a living so basically what I do
all day every day is I go into a
classroom and I point at kids and I ask
them well they're young adults and ask
them to speak and then I ask everybody
else to listen to them and respond to
them and if I'm doing my job right I
don't have to say anything right when it
works well it's them all listening and
having a conversation with each other so
yeah I do believe that it's it's
possible to train them and to train
ourselves in that kind of listening what
I'm kind of dreading is the industry
that you know in Josh's Utopia we have
where we're all subjected to trainings
on how to listen and maybe it's just my
allergy to trainings in general which is
maybe it's not a heresy it's like the
opposite of heresy most people don't
love trainings
is that it would just I feel very
quickly devolve into one of the things
we don't want you know the spitting back
or the mirroring or the I mean those are
all fine techniques but they're not
genuine listening but no additional
contrast sorry go ahead no I want to
discuss some other people in this so
it's not too so Maggie or Tim do you
have anything to add to this I was I was
gonna ask Maggie yeah Maggie please okay
I mean I think that let's hear I a lot
of the times I speak anecdotally right
I'm not from the same culture y'all are
from and the way that listening is
modeled
in the cultures that it appears y'all
grew up in it's not what listening looks
like in other cultures anywhere else on
earth right so for example
how do I say this without getting myself
in trouble
when I hang out with my mother-in-law
right
she listens she's been trained to listen
she's
turns into a little bit of an
interrogation
right you keep asking more and more
questions of the same person and you dig
down Dig Down dig down but there's no
sharing of yourself there
right so how do you even know that that
information is being consumed and
understood and internalized or is this
like an algorithmic performance right so
as opposed to in my culture when you
listen to someone the way that you show
that you understand and relate is that
you respond back with an anecdote and
story from your own life
that illustrates the same point and if
you're not used to that structure it
sounds like you're full of yourself
right it sounds like you're trying to
dominate the conversation with your own
[__] but in reality what you're
showing is you're relating you deeply
understand the topic at hand because
you're like I have had a similar
experience and a conversation predicated
on that concept of listening sounds like
two people who aren't even having the
same conversation to someone from like
middle class America right so I think
that that's the tough thing here is that
the way that we are acculturated to
converse and listen isn't uniform even
in the United States much less you know
worldwide so I don't know how applicable
this type of like Noah says training or
whatever intervention would actually be
that's my my take and Tim what's your
response to this heresy I'm just
enjoying how quickly this all got fired
up
I was eager to see where it would go so
I'm just enjoying the initial fireworks
I would say that I am inclined to ask
Josh more questions because I heard Noah
who's
no's good at sparring too he said you
know in Josh's Utopia and I was like
well wait a second is that Josh's Utopia
maybe we should clarify
what Josh means and specifically since
this is my job as the prescriptive
podcaster I suppose maybe it's Thomas
Moore's Utopia
my inclination is also just to say all
right well let's let's take the
some of the sort of broader statements
and maybe refine it down to Josh's
personal experience coming back to this
sharing of anecdotes it doesn't need to
be some RCT
in your experience Josh since you have
changed your mind on this it seems what
have you found most helpful
to
help to inform the experience of genuine
listening on the part of people you are
having conversations with
so to your point Tim
my experience is deeply formed by my
wife's experience and so I recognize
everyone's a little contrary to Kevin's
original point my wife started out as a
non-profit litigator representing
survivors of interpersonal violence and
she would go to court and have a
horrible case after a horrible case and
she did an amazing job representing
these women who were facing just
unbearable personal situations and after
years and years of that she found it
difficult and there's a lot of vicarious
trauma in that profession and she
ultimately migrated and got retrained as
a mediator where she now helps
low-income couples avoid court and work
through mediation on the orders of
custody and separation and through that
process she went from being a really
hard edged although she's a very deeply
empathetic person but a need to have a
really tough veneer because she was a
litigator to being retrained as a
mediator and she would come home after
three days of training and I would get
really helpful instruction and I would
say that I started someplace like Noah
or maybe even further from NOAA on this
whole subject and I think it may have
reflected my own personal experience
like Noah with some corporate
institutional type trainings which made
me skeptical about whether in fact these
things could be done
and just listening to Antoinette week
after week year after year and watching
her and seeing how she demonstrated it
was super compelling and it totally
changed the nature of our interaction
and it totally changed the way I try to
work in my professional life as well it
was as profound as anything else I had
been taught in my professional life and
I learned it at home in our kitchen so I
think I feel it so strongly partly
because I learned from a woman I admire
and it changed my life quite directly
y'all are straw man and Noah okay yeah
it's okay that's my job
so Josh what's an example of a technique
that you learned that was really helpful
I think a lot of it has to do Kevin
actually with what you were talking
about in terms of active listening and
for me the piece that is hardest and I
wish I were a lot better at it and I'm
quite confident over the course of this
podcast I'll demonstrate that I haven't
learned it as effectively as I should
have and that's the difficulty of course
with this topic right because you guys
are all Lucky me like doesn't look like
he's learned that much on this maybe he
should go back to school but I think the
piece that's most effective and has
helped me the most and as I said it's
really not just in the context of our
relationship but with our friendships
and at work is trying to come at these
conversations from a place of empathy
and really asking myself why why is this
person reacting in the way that she is
why is this guy so angry what is
upsetting her what is upsetting him what
is the underlying root and there's an
expression in this area which is going
down the V which is to say you have to
go down and understand the root of the
issue and try to come at it from a place
of empathy and if you can do those
things Your Capacity to hear to listen
to adjust is likely to be increased to
Noah's point
often one won't agree right this isn't
about saying we all need to get along
this isn't about necessarily always
cooperating there are things out there
in the world about which I feel very
strongly and I'm totally antithetical to
my belief system this is about having
the capacity at least of having some
empathy I do so also want to pick up on
matic's point quickly I totally agree
with you Maggie there is not a
one-size-fits-all to this and you know
what you described in terms of sharing
anecdote sounds lovely the version of
that that operates in New York is
horrible you go out to lunch with a guy
and you say you know my daughter's not
feeling great for X Y reasons and he
immediately responds by saying my
daughter's got the same problem it's
like that's not really demonstrating
empathy that's just talking about
yourself so I think it's got to be done
in a way that is appropriate for the
community in which it's being taught
yeah I don't know nothing about New York
to be fair yeah yeah Maggie can I ask
you a question when you were talking
about you belong to multiple overlapping
answers I guess we all do
when you talked about your culture where
that where what you the appropriate
response is to say I've had a similar
experience which of your cultures were
you talking about
that's more kind of location based right
I'm indigenous but it's not so much that
this is just how people speak where I'm
from right and around Hephzibah Georgia
this is like deep rural built in place
Southeastern stuff and to the point that
you know after how many years I've been
gone from home and kind of trained in
this other way of being polite you know
with the air quotes and everything
I remember going back home and having a
conversation with my mom and my pawpaw
and his wife my step-grandmother and
they just looked at me like I was an
alien right we were trying to have a
conversation and I was like asking
questions and she was just looking at me
like I'd grown a third head and I was
like oh
all right like I've been I've been led a
stray this isn't about politeness it's a
cultural thing right
and you know when you live in a liminal
cultural space like I constantly do
where you've got all these weird
overlapping cultures that are hard to
disarticulate sometimes you get slapped
in the face with reality like that right
sure
so
is there anything else we want to add to
to Josh's heresy before maybe move on to
to another one I think it was a great
starting place so I'll let you quote it
back as you see fit okay Dr Kelly
so Noah
would you like to volunteer a heresy
that you have and
subjected to the group sure
it's always hard to narrow down the
things you think that the people around
you think are terrible because I got a
lot of them
horrible it's just that we don't believe
so I'm going to take one that comes from
my my professional sphere but as a
professional sphere that a lot of people
care about which is constitutions
broadly speaking okay intentional
agreements between people to do
something a certain way
and my heresy is that written
Constitutions are seriously overrated
okay and this is coming from somebody
who's devoted most of my life to
studying mostly written constitutions
and you know when anyone will let me
trying to help people write them
so it's like a self-harming heresy and
just to articulate why I think it yeah
it's the best kind right
is that
we think that if we have an agreement
written down
between us and this is not only at the
Constitutional level but it could be
like an agreement with your partner or
even with your business partner like a
contract like a contract we think well
we have a contract it's written down and
because it's written down we're going to
keep it because there's some consequence
if we don't keep it and we also think
that we'll both know what the agreement
is because we can look at the piece of
paper that it's written on and all of
those propositions turn out when you
look at them more closely to be false
you're keeping the agreement because you
each think it's worth keeping the
agreement at a given moment and you
might change your minds about that and
you might break the agreement without
telling the other person or you might
jointly decide to change it without
bothering to change the writing
if you think someone's breaking their
promise to you and you say hey look at
this piece of paper where you wrote down
their promise that'll basically never
get them to do the thing you want them
to do
and the whole approach forgets that it
over emphasizes the idea that language
is clear which it isn't
and it overemphasizes the idea that
we've agree if we've agreed to something
at one moment we're stuck with that
thing forever we're not and in the case
of a country if we ran the country the
way the constitution of 1787 was written
we'd still have to be living like it was
1787. and that's not viable and we
actually don't amend our constitution
barely ever in the United States we just
change what it means by a whole
complicated set of processes some
official and some unofficial and so now
if you look at the written Constitution
it doesn't really bear any relationship
to what it was supposed to be originally
and that's fine
what that shows you is what if we hadn't
written it down at all you know what if
we had just agreed to live together as a
community and work things out as we went
that would have been closer to what it's
like to be married to somebody or to be
in a long-term business relationship
with somebody where you're constantly
modifying and altering and shifting and
changing so the the heresy is that we
think this is so great and we think it
because we've been patting ourselves on
the back and saying that in the U.S for
200 plus years and the Really here's the
kicker when we wrote down our
constitution in the U.S basically no one
else had ever had a written Constitution
and now almost every country in the
world has a written Constitution which
means we've convinced people all over
the world basically with the exception
of Great Britain and Saudi Arabia that
this is the greatest thing since sliced
bread and you have to have one if you
want to be a democracy you got to have
this so we've convinced everybody of
this idea that's it's verging on
[__] it doesn't map reality and so I
think that's you know it's not something
that the people around me would agree
with at all and you know they've got a
million good arguments about why I'm
wrong and I'd love to hear how you guys
react to it so the heresy is that
written Constitutions are overrated
so
what's the
alternative to it that's underrated and
actually if I may jump in and maybe know
if you'd be able to use a real world
example like you mentioned the UK
perhaps that's a good Counterpoint
speaking of someone who's really not
familiar with the inner workings and the
way that you are
the question of what the alternative
would be is interesting and maybe
leading into that you could just say
when you
developed this heresy for yourself has
this been something that you've believed
for 15 years this is the last five years
what led to it and then what would be an
example of an alternative because
speaking as an idiot who doesn't know
anything about these things I have all
these board games laying around you open
the board game what's the first thing
you do you figure out the rules and that
keeps everybody on the same page so to
my knuckle dragging Long Island self I'm
like well if you don't have a set of
written down rules wouldn't it just be
complete chaos especially in the US with
a bunch of separate states and blah blah
blah blah so is it chaos when you play
pool
not if you agree on the rules in advance
that's a good question yeah fair enough
as long as you agree in some form in
advance not necessarily depends on the
number of drinks I've had but yeah it's
generally okay Noah
it's something I came to very very
slowly because like you I always thought
we need the rules and I cared about it
enough to you know go into this is my
living so I definitely was not an early
life realization I think I had way too
much faith in the idea of stuff being
written down and I think the way I came
to it was by actually being in the
middle of processes where people were
writing down rules from scratch where
they were as they were making up the
rules of the board game and Iraq and in
Tunisia and realizing that actually
nobody necessarily intends to follow the
rules the way they're written down they
just see the rules as kind of a vague
suggestion that will ultimately come to
be distorted and changed played around
with and that's actually I used to think
that was a bad thing and I came to see
that that was a good thing
and then if there was one idea that
really made me realize that I was kind
of wrong about the rules of the game and
I remember reading this really clearly I
read it in graduate school but I didn't
understand it for years afterwards
it's this idea that conversation this
actually might bring us back to Josh
that conversation language is also like
a game
like a game you say like a game yeah so
like we're up to five of us are having a
conversation and there actually are a
bunch of rules of that conversation
regarding who can speak and when and how
and grammar and there's also a ton that
isn't written down in there you know we
don't have a paradigm exactly for
Interruption and we'll all have
different Interruption styles to
Maggie's point if we're from different
parts of the country we'll have
different Interruption Styles if we have
a different class upbringing or gender
upbringing we'll have different styles
if we speak different languages we'll
have different Interruption Styles just
to take one example and in fact we're
just making up the rules of that game as
we go same when you know invent a new
word like who's the first person who you
know thought that
that the word cool meant what it now has
come to mean you know whoever first said
that people probably looked at that
person like what are you talking about
that this music is cool like cool what
right you introduce a new word and then
other people use it and you play around
with it so you're playing this game and
so that game doesn't have rules and from
there I didn't understand when I first
learned this at all I was like this is
interesting but I don't get it I came to
realize
that actually you know life is a lot
more like a game of catch right than
like a board game Tim so if we're
playing catch
you know there's a whole bunch of
Unwritten stuff like do we bounce the
ball to each other sometimes we do do we
throw it hard like when kids do it like
when you're trying to see how hard the
other person can handle it we do that
sometimes too you know sometimes we'll
be just lobbing it there's like all this
Unwritten stuff in a game of catch it's
definitely a game and there's some rule
like throw it to each other and throw it
back but then everything else is kind of
being played with along the way and
that's why it can change how can that
work on a nationwide basis
if you could just paint an alternative
since yeah I don't know what that looks
like the most aggressive version would
be the British constitution which
depending on how you count you could say
is a thousand years old you could say
it's you know 400 plus years old you
could put the inflection point at
different moments and by the way there's
been civil wars in the middle of it too
so it's not like it's perfect by any
stretch of the imagination
but what you had there is that the
people who were doing the governing the
people who were criticizing the way the
governing was happening and the people
who were being governed
collectively experimented with different
ways of doing things
and they shifted their Collective
understanding over time in an
evolutionary way and all of them
basically admitted that things were
changing over time
none of them ever said I can point to
this piece of paper and tell you this is
exactly
you know who can run for office or this
is exactly what the king or the queen
can do and sure they had mess-ups along
the way lots of them but it turns out
not really more mess-ups than any other
system and they maintained a high degree
of continuity
and you know again they had a civil war
they had a revolution so it's not like
it was totally seamless
but they were able to negotiate moments
of big change in transition often more
smoothly than other countries and
they've got the best longevity of a
governing system of any country and if
you measure it in those terms that's
pretty that's pretty darn successful and
what's more I would just close that by
saying countries like ours that have an
old written Constitution we do all that
same stuff too we just lie about it we
just pretend that we're not doing that
right Maggie maybe you hit something
yeah I mean the other long-term example
of this is the hode nashoni Confederacy
right so this is what a lot of people
call the Iroquois League right these are
the the the six nations in Upstate New
York and crossing over into Canada in
the modern day that have had a kind of
living spoken Constitution complete with
federalism for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years prior to European
invasion of North America and and the
physical manifestation of that
government
you still have that right you still have
an item that is the
the thing to point to it just doesn't
have words per se on it so you have
these wampum belts that have figural
depictions of agreements woven onto them
right and
you know even beyond what happens in the
UK
that Constitution has survived an
apocalypse
it still exists and is in working order
today and they're the strongest Nation
indigenous nation in
the Eastern Americas because of the
strength of that spoken Constitution and
I think to what Noah's saying is you
know we talk about this a lot it's kind
of the difference between the word of
the law and the spirit of the law right
when you write something down you can
play a different kind of game than what
Noel was talking about right you can
start playing you get all these people
who are interested in trying to find the
seams and the cracks in an agreement to
change the meaning rather than trying to
adhere to the original point of what the
agreement was you start having people
trying to to rip it apart
to suit new needs rather than adhere to
what the point was right this is why it
didn't end up becoming a lawyer actually
so no I I want to clarify something so
it seems to me that there's saying that
the written Constitution is overrated
that there are several things one is we
have something that's a language based
Constitution and there's issues with
having as Magazine having it based
around language then there's the
additional one of the written language
so you're saying there's additional
level of difficulty because it's written
down and that as far as I can see what
you're saying is that it's because
writing is sort of immutable and then
that becomes a problem as time
progressed because you don't want the
immutable things you want things to be
mutable
and so writing is the immutable version
of the language
and so are you saying that you don't
want to have a language-based agreement
or that
you just don't want to have a written
immutable version of the language
agreements what I'm trying to say is
closer to the the second thing you're
saying okay I'm not sure
I can't imagine what it would be like to
reach agreement without language at all
at scale I mean you know you can have
symbols like Maggie was talking about
that are super powerful and maybe can't
be reduced solely to language but on the
other hand if you ask people who have
been the bearers of that Constitution
you know for 300 plus years
they could tell you what it is and they
could tell you in language what the
particular image on the particular
wampum belt is signifying so it's not
that I'm trying to imagine a world
without language I'm not saying it's
impossible I just can't do it I'm not
good enough at it
I am talking though about our fantasy
that if we've written something down now
we know and now that agreement is
genuinely fixed and you know you could
also think of it just in terms of
regular contracts right you know I mean
you think you know you made a contract
with someone that you're going to shovel
their snow and they're going to pay you
you know X dollars every time there's a
snowstorm and you're like okay I'm great
I'm good and then like you get like a
dusting of snow and you go run right out
and you shovel up the dusting and you
send them a bill
you know and they're like what the hell
that was not a shoveling of snow and now
you immediately find yourself what
matters is not what the words shovel
mean or snow mean what matters is like
how much they like you do you intend to
shovel their snow next year
you know what kind of social ties do you
have with them so that it'll be an issue
if you stiff them or they stiff you
those are the relational issues the
relationship issues are the really the
most important ones that come in and
they will determine what's going to
happen now you imagine that between two
people and it's definitely the same like
you can't really get up and invoke your
wedding vows you know you promise to
love and honor me but now you're not
doing it I mean you could try that but
it doesn't always work so maybe it works
in Josh's house where everyone listens
but you know the rest of the world it
doesn't always work that well now I
gotta jump in oh no broken the bear
exactly thank you Tim so first of all I
totally admire the fact that Noah chose
a topic where we would be somewhere
between idiotic and foolish to debate it
with him does anyone really want to get
on this show and say you know what I
think I'm going to take on the Felix
frankfitter professor of constitutional
law at the Harvard Law School over a
subject of whether Constitutions are
valid I'm not signing up for that one no
thank you
in two ways one is I totally take his
point about the UK and Maggie's point
about the Six Nations there's a big
Survivor bias element of that yeah you
can always point to the example which
has survived and say yeah great
unfortunately there are a lot of
examples of where it doesn't survive and
therefore we don't point to those but so
I'm not sure those examples are entirely
valid notwithstanding the strength of
the cultures and the histories I would
say on the subject of contracts and
that's why I know as a constitutional
Professor not a contract law professor
because if he was a contracts law
professor he wouldn't have made that
case I really disagree look contracts
serve important purposes and here's what
they are one is they force a discussion
up front like they allow people to align
expectations without that process I
don't know what you expect now let's
leave aside marriages because I think
prenuptials are unlikely to work and I
agree with you wedding vows are done at
a highly romantic moment but in business
in the real world what you do is you say
you're buying something I'm selling
something let's figure out what that
means and make sure that we've agreed on
the fundamental terms and that's an
important process and the other thing it
does is it forces you to understand
consequences if you don't live up to
your side of the agreement and that's a
very useful technique as well so it's
possible that this discovery that Noah
made a burning man last year that his
lifelong work in the constitution is no
longer valid that's conceivable to me it
seems unlikely but it's possible I don't
think it's necessarily applicable
however if you extend it out into the
rest of the world and using wedding vows
as the extreme example generally
speaking I think is a little bit of a
false analogy just to be fair I'll say
Josh likes poking Bears too
going back to the kind of immutable
aspect of it to me that actually the
true genius was not the first writing
down of the Constitution of the US was
the fact that it had a self-amendment
clause that is that is a real genius and
I think actually it was the Six Nations
that influenced the self-amendment and
so there's something buried in there
there is a facility to do that so I
would say in Constitution without a
self-amendment clause or facility
would be really worrisome but once you
have that in to me that could overcome
some of the immutability aspect of it
you just want to have it easier to
mutate so right now we kind of penalize
because it's kind of more difficult to
change the Constitution than it was to
pass the Constitution and so there
you're penalizing the future Generations
so wouldn't you just want to make it
easier to to change things if that was
the real hurdle
actually could I modify that question
Kevin is it are you okay with that sure
so I'm going to build off of that so the
question Noah
is very closely related what I would ask
to Kevin's which is let's say we could
wipe some of the polarization in the U.S
and we're kind of starting from scratch
in a culture that at least informed by
sort of
Western and European influence by and
large does not have for the majority of
the country a strong hand-down oral
tradition
what might you suggest as a better way
to put things together
now you guys win a minute really hard so
let me go through them in order so I'll
start with with Josh's point I agree
Josh that if you're strangers and you
need to you know sell each other some
commodity you need a written contract
with all the details I'm not imagining
that you know you could run the the
Futures Trading markets by you know
purely conventional terms with nothing
written down though I will note that
there are markets like the diamond
markets where people's transactions are
overwhelmingly still to this day based
on a handshake and a bunch of rules that
are not written down in any one place
but that depends on being a close-knit
community of people who know each other
this already hints it the answer to
Tim's point so I guess what I would say
is imagine that you've got two pulls of
Continuum on the one side are pork
bellies
you know sold by people who never never
seen a pork belly to each other and
never will see one and on the other hand
is wedding vows which are highly
conventional general principles at a
high level designed maybe to inspire you
to manage to live well together over the
long run
I'm saying my heresy is that
Constitutions are on that continuum
closer to
wedding vows where the goal is to be
together for a long time and to adjust
and evolve and change
and be responsive than they are to Pork
bellies and I think that's the heresy so
that raises the question of change right
so Kevin you're right that amending a
constitution is crucial but
unfortunately our wonderful Founders did
a terrible job in putting in a an
amendment provision if they wanted us to
actually amend the Constitution which
secretly they didn't Madison was
terrified about the possibility of too
much Amendment he thought it would end
up like the Florida Constitution or the
California Constitution or one of these
constitutions with hundreds and hundreds
in some cases you know nearly a thousand
amendments
so they made it too hard to amend and
that's why we have to do all of these
mechanisms in aren't amendment to change
it Tim I think you're making an
incredibly rich and Powerful point which
is if we don't have common Traditions
necessarily and we're also a country of
both of immigrants
and of people who change their views
even aside from the polarization it
makes us look more like Traders trading
pork bellies who don't have anything in
common with each other I mean they
actually do in real life but let's
imagine they didn't for example they all
wear the same Patagonia vest but it
makes us seem more like that than it
does like a married couple and I guess
here's what I would say
that's a reason to have a written thing
up front
and then to try to use that to build up
a culture in which we do share common
values
and if we don't have enough of the
common values we're not going to pull it
off and that's why polarization is so
scary
I mean we've had polarizing moments in
our history before this is not our most
polarized moment it's not even the
second most polarized but it's still it
is very polarized and the reason that in
general is scary is at a certain point
if you don't have enough in common with
somebody you know if the situation is
not working you know you might break up
and this is not a situation where
there's the option of some clean breakup
you know so that's terrifying and it's
why you need to build up some sense of
common values and beliefs and a
constitution is a good starting place
that way recognizing that it's not going
to run all the way down through history
with all the details specified so
talking it over at first is great like
Josh says but then as hundreds of years
pass you know if we got together and had
a new Constitutional Convention today
and said oh let's just talk it over I
don't think it would reach an agreement
you know so we sometimes need something
that is general and loose enough like
marriage vows that we can all say well I
know what that means I know what that
means and we think they mean almost
opposite things
so unless someone has something else to
add to this heresy discussion I'd like
to move it on to the next one anyone
else have anything more to say on Noah's
really great yeah great wonderful
unexpected so Maggie what's a heresy
you'd like to share with us
yeah I think
American middle class cultures ruining
America
middle class culture is ruining middle
America and All America yeah it's
ruining everything it's ruining
literally okay yeah I mean we export
ourselves so maybe it's ruining the
whole world let's just extend it let's
get out there on a limb right when I say
that though really what do I mean
I kind of mean American modernism right
the type of America that's existed
post-world War II
where we instill in people a certain set
of values right
we've adjusted our culture you know you
tell your youth that to be a successful
and respected member of society you
leave home at 17 or 18. go somewhere
where you don't know anybody go to
college right and then if you're
successful you can start up a little
nuclear family
out in a nameless suburb or a town that
has the same amenities that every town
has and live a successful kind of
the berry in life right
a little Protestant ethic in the spirit
of capitalism in there right this is a
very particular cultural brand and as
we're no longer in the heady Glory Days
economically of what America was able to
achieve after the world was destroyed
and we were the only people that had
like working machines anymore okay
as some of those
pockets of fat have dissolved in the
United States
we've been left in this situation where
you get extreme social isolation
you get kids that
can't get into the ivy league even
though they feel like they're entitled
to it and then they go spend all their
Time online become in cells buy AR-15
and shoot up a school
right
and I think that it's because we've
really moved away from the idea of
community
in terms of being embedded in a place
you know there are other European
countries with economic issues look at
Italy look at Greece right but they
don't have the same end result because
those people are still embedded in a
community of people who care about them
who interact with them
and you don't have this extreme social
isolation you don't it's just
it's all cultural process in my opinion
you know it's a similar thing with
I think that leads a lot of people to
these extremely Escapist drug addictions
right
and you know to Josh's point I'm not
talking about Burning Man
right I'm talking about the kind of drug
issues I see in
Worcester Massachusetts right so
yeah I think that this extreme adherence
to the
to that particular brand of the American
dream has ruined our ability to have a
functional I mean things have just
become quite dysfunctional in the
country because of it so I'm I'm trying
to again refine the heresy with the it
is so you said it was American Dream but
then you said it was maybe more modern
because modernism yeah I'm thinking
about the hundreds of millions of people
in China
who have left their communities and
moved into the cities and so is this
what you're talking about or is it
something different than this and the
same thing is happening in India right
now where there are
the same kind of migration is happening
of people living leaving these little
Villages that are where they have a
certain identity they know who they are
they're moving into big cities they're
going to college and Beyond they're
mixing up they're they're isolated is
that what we're we're talking about this
as a general phenomena or you're saying
that there's something else different
than this
yeah I think I do mean it a little bit
more pointed than gradual urbanization
due to like change economically globally
yeah I think there is a particular brand
of the American version of this that
and honestly the people who are most
harmed by it I think are young men
young white men in America right they're
feeling
this sea change under their feet right
we have
there are more women going to college
than men
for a decade now right why
in America
a lot of it is because men are just not
achieving you know dumb metrics that are
kind of meaningless like SAT scores and
gpas at the same rate as women in the
United States I think that it's all
American culture bounded where
if you're failing to meet this High kind
of what's the what's the this Billy
Crystal standard you know from movies in
the 80s and 90s of being able to strike
out on your own with just a baseball bat
and an army duffel bag full of stuff
walking into New York City to like start
your life that you have failed and I
think people are being told that they're
literal failures because they're not
able to achieve this very time
constrained version of American success
and that a lot of the people who are
doing some of the worst things in the
United States right now are people who
have gone through that experience of
failure it's not necessary
I don't know that there's any analog to
that type of failure in modern China or
India and I'm pretty sure there isn't a
version of that in Italy or Greece you
live with your parents you go to college
and then you move down the street when
you get married right
can I ask Maggie how much of this is the
stuff part like the part that you might
call consumer culture you know that we
measure ourselves by how much stuff we
have and how good that stuff is and the
brands that go with it and then if you
want that you need cash and to get that
cash you move to the city because that's
where the job is that pays more cash
then you just meet more people who want
the same stuff
you know I how much of it is the stuff
part of it and how much of it is the
dream of making it big like you know the
the fantasy of becoming the next Elon
and how much of it is the leaving where
you grew up
to go to a new place because all those
seem to be part of what you're
describing yeah absolutely
absolutely Beyond
right and keeping up with the Joneses
type stuff to meaningless achievements
right like what's the real difference
from getting a degree from the
University of Georgia versus Emory
in terms of your life trajectory not
that huge but if you don't get into
Emory right and you have to go to
Georgia Southern suddenly that's like
almost like a narcissistic injury right
where you have this
hit to your ego you can never recover
from right and it's just constant
knocking down of ego that injures people
in this way emotionally what I'm arguing
is that those standards are [__]
stupid to begin with like they're not
based in anything other than the
imagination of what we could achieve on
the GI bill in 1950 you know at a time
where we had far fewer people
in the country we had a far different
economic Outlook
and you know I really don't think it's
necessarily about leaving home which I
mean for me it is right personally I'm
coming from this again from an outsider
point of view I didn't grow up in this
type of culture but I'm surrounded by it
all the time now right so
it's all bound up with it but I think
it's more this like absolute like you
said about the Constitution the written
Constitution this fiction we've created
this fantasy of what you need to just
have a basic like respectable life
in upper middle class America
right it doesn't matter how much money
you make even if you're an underwater
welder are you getting the same respect
as someone who went to Cornell
you know in upper middle class Boston
like I don't know that you are even if
you're making double the money
so quick question for you Maggie
yeah and I'll just add a little backdrop
so Johan Hari is an author from getting
his name pronounced correctly he's
written books about addiction and also
depression chasing the scream lost
connections and he returns in a very
compelling way over and over again to
social isolation and I suppose what I'm
wondering is as I look at cultures that
I understand somewhat like Japan for
instance the schooling there and cram
schools and test scores are even more
determinant in a way of your future than
say the SATs are in the US however and
there are social isolation issues in
Japan but you have multi-generational
households and you look at a place like
Costa Rica multi-generational households
and I'm wondering if that is a Crux
component of all of this which it seems
to be is there anything to be done in
the U.S are there changes that you think
we could make culturally that would
remedy some of the symptoms that you're
describing
yeah I mean maybe celebrate people whose
lives are happy
I mean as that's the form of success
that we should be like
lionizing above meeting what is frankly
like you said right you just said oh
there's multi-generational households in
Japan and there's this really toxic
testing culture right
you know if you think about it in you
know not to get too theoretical here in
an organismic way right where these
different facets of culture work like
different organs and a system as a whole
right like a body that forms a culture
very like Dirk High man way of thinking
about things
you know maybe you can pick pieces in
and out there like you're explaining
these other cultures that you have
experience with somehow in America we've
picked a set of organs that lead to a
particularly toxic
end right toxic individualism
right individualism at all costs really
right we we don't have maternity leave
right like it's just like we don't have
Universal Health Care there's stuff that
just makes economic even neoliberal
sense that we don't do because of like
toxic individualism and I do think that
if we started focusing on again
lionizing people who live happy lives
they'll have fulfilled lives rather than
ones who meet this American archetype
Don Draper
right that that could lead to a lot of
good change you know Josh I think you
had your hand up so I react to a couple
different ways to this Maggie the first
is you know if you live in New York City
you have a lot of politicians who come
here to ask for your advice then they
quickly pivot to asking for money but it
gives you a chance at least to hear from
them and I try to ask them what's
something true about your constituents
that I wouldn't know and one of them
said to me once you think all my
constituents want to move to New York
City they don't the problem is they
don't have yes they don't have jobs
where they want to live so the first way
I react to this I totally agree and I
think we are failing to your point Tim
as a society
when we failed to provide employment
opportunities meaningful work a sense of
purpose in the communities where people
actually want to live and we should not
assume that everyone wants to move to
New York City and work for a meta and
live in a loft in SoHo although even if
you work for Meadow you probably
couldn't afford a loft and Soho so that
part I really react to Maggie and I
agree with you I probably disagree with
you slightly on part of it if you look
at places like Italy and China just
picking two examples what you cited
probably their biggest problem going
forward is a demographic one where they
have some of the lowest birth rates in
the world so you pick two societies and
held them up particularly Italy is place
where things are going well I would say
a society where people are sufficiently
pessimistic about the world that they're
unwilling to have children and where
they have repeatedly voted into office
someone like Berlusconi let alone the
person they have now yeah probably
aren't society as I always hold up as
exemplars of what our aspirations should
be so I'm not sure I agree with you on
that point and then the third thing I'd
probably say is the male that you're
describing I think are real I think
that's a Confluence of things though I
think one element absolutely is
consumerism one element certainly is
social media dislocation they're all
combined but if I had to come back to
one I probably would go back to the
point you made and where I started which
is we're failing to provide meaningful
employment a sense of purpose the
capacity to support yourself and you
support your family in a community that
you find meaningful and we've assumed
that's only one type of community and
that's a failing as a society
it makes me think of again I think
anecdotally we kind of started this
whole conversation with me with me
responding
or I started in this conversation with
responding to Josh about
how I normally Converse in my culture
and I will now show an example of that
right my I have a very large tight-knit
family that lives on a compound
okay we all live on the same piece of
land we've had to land for 300 years we
got it for service in the revolution
okay I'm related to most of the people
where I'm from
the exact piece of land
we all went to high school together we
all went to middle school together right
and some of us including myself are
considered in our culture big weirdos
people who would be targets of bullying
people who would don't fit into the norm
of the area
but having the social network of cousins
in this example to help guide you
through social situations that you don't
understand on the ground as a peer who
loves you in your your school and then
threatening to kick someone's ass who
tries to come at you right gives you a
way to navigate through some of what are
the most scarring times for a lot of
these kids who are totally disassociated
from a community right you hear about
all of these male adjustments and
there's just
I spend a lot of time online to my
physical and emotional detriment
and you just see these communities of
young men that are just
spiraling
spiraling and I have cousins who could
have gone down that path but instead you
know live normal lives now right
because we were there to kick someone's
ass who tried to come at them yeah
can I just say you know the more I hear
you say that Maggie the more I think
that the problem might just not be in
modern America it might be like
everyone in the U.S who who's descendant
of immigrants to a certain degree
because so few people descended of
immigrants in the U.S formed familial
compounds where they stayed you know
mostly people move a lot and that's
always been true since European you know
since Europeans first came to to the
Americas
to North America so some of this problem
may go back even even further and the
other thing is to my mind it's
associated with this problem of social
class that we don't like to talk about
in the United States you know classes
like this the c word of our public
conversations on the one hand There's
Something Beautiful about that
post-world War II moment where as we're
constantly being told by the economists
there was a lot of Mobility possible in
the United States and in the U.S because
we never had an aristocracy
Mobility was often measured by did you
go to college and at first there weren't
very many colleges so going to college
was a way to bump up then after the GI
Bill there were a lot more colleges but
it was still we still treated it as a
way to bump ourselves up and now it's
obviously a lot harder for reasons you
were describing for anyone to bump up
and so we know about this kind of
Mobility problem but what you're saying
and this is why I like it and it's also
so radical and it's really making me
think
is that it's actually even before that
it's that you know even just the idea
that you can move up implies that you
should want to move up and that there's
something not okay with you if you don't
and in a way what you're describing is a
kind of like downside of Mobility it's
not just the lack of Mobility you're
saying even if we had the mobility it
still sends the wrong message to people
who are like I don't want to be mobile I
like who I am I like where I live I like
what I do and that is something which
I think it's hard to find any period in
U.S history where European descended or
or other immigrant descended Americans
were consistently happy with saying I'm
just going to stay where I am and do my
thing
and you know I went to college at
Harvard I'm a beast of a certain mold
like Noah is
you know we had this you know Uncle
Harvard there looming in the background
for a lot of our lives and you'd be
shocked at how many people acted like I
was out of my mind for not wanting to
spend my time dragging the American
South
for being the place where a lot of the
worst Sins Of America were was it
peroximed out right
or tried to we pretended right
The Whipping Boy of the entire United
States that I didn't want to talk about
how awful it was and get away from it
and you know that I spend my time
proselytizing to people from home about
the fact that yeah I mean Donald Trump
really is the con man snake oil salesman
from New York you told me to be scared
of when I moved to New England you know
it's here he's here he showed up y'all
maybe pay attention right and I get
treated like it's crazy that I don't
want to live in New York City that I
don't I'm not interested in it I have my
people
and I have my culture right Josh you had
something maybe conflating a couple
things one is mobility with a sense of
Economic Security
I think Maggie's completely right that
not everyone wants to move know your
rights at the history of the United
States required movement and why was
that it was because
parts of the country had a stagnant
economy and parts of the country almost
always had a booming economy and people
who were looking to better themselves
from an economic perspective and
prioritize that that was a question of
choice one can argue about whether
that's the right choice but they found
Mobility as the most compelling way to
improve their lot
interestingly over the last couple of
years mobility in the United States has
declined dramatically that was partly
covet related it's partly also people
are re-prioritizing right they're
recognizing I think a little bit Maggie
what you're saying which is
that new job that 20 pay raise is less
important to me in some respects than
maintaining a sense of community in a
sense of place and I'm going to
prioritize those I think we just have to
be willing to acknowledge that if that's
going to work though we need to be
creating jobs around the country leaving
aside one's views on work right to work
if you go to Greenville South Carolina
why is that Community vibrant is because
we have a lot of Auto plants and we've
moved Auto plants out of one particular
place which was the Midwest and we've
moved them to places where other people
want to live you don't even have to live
in the town of Greenville City of
Greenville you can live outside in quite
rural South Carolina and have a job that
will pay you a living wage Boeing's in
Charleston South Carolina that works for
the people who work at Boeing and
Manufacturing assemble 787 Dreamliners
so I think our conception of where
people want to live and work needs to
change and I think we need to recognize
that and provide those opportunities so
I completely agree but it's a different
question than upward mobility and I
don't think we should diminish the
historical and relatively healthy
American desire for our children to have
a better lives and quotes than what we
had and part of that realistically is
economically it's not just having more
meaningful relationships for people who
have not had means it's important that
they have an opportunity to have more
Financial Security
so
I feel as if maybe we should move on
unless Maggie do you have anything final
to say on your heresy or is that enough
my last sentence would be if you can
just move from one
suburb a thousand miles to another
suburb and you don't feel culturally
uncomfortable you are doing it wrong
okay already really good so Mr Tim yes
sir what's your heresy I know you have a
heresy deep inside you so tell us what
it is
I've been racking my brain on this for a
little while because I didn't want to
start with something so nearly
impossible to defend that it would be
unproductive
so I think what I'm going to go with is
I have come to a point where I believe
there are multiple vehicles through
which we will be able to meaningfully
communicate with animals
within the next five years I would say
and by meaningful I've thought about
what that actually means like would it
be at the level of a small human child I
don't think that the conceptual mapping
will work quite that way but there are a
couple of things that have combined for
me to believe this one on the on maybe
the easier to grasp side would be work
that people like azer Raskin are
presenting and exploring related to
using Ai and
machine learning and so on to
effectively decode
and then produce communication with
different species and there's a fair
amount of progress that's been made with
say whales and a whale guy yeah exactly
remember his name okay yeah I haven't
met the well guy I've seen the book
though and so I do think technology and
in this case literally sort of
exponentially
developing technology will put a huge
dent in that in a very short period of
time and of course Kevin you've spent a
lot of time in the sandbox of AI so you
know how absurdly quickly things are
developing and surprising the developers
themselves now I'm going to throw a
Twist on that to make it a little
stranger
which is a few other things that I think
will help with animal communication
are sensory augmentation
so that there could be potentially
real-time interaction along the lines of
say what neuroscientist David Eagleman
has done where they put on say a suit
for someone who is blind or deaf and it
provides a tactile form of feedback
where they begin to map their
environment and inputs differently and
they and adapt to this very very quickly
and furthermore this is this is the last
I'll say and I'll stop I think that a
certain psychedelic compounds will
probably facilitate a number of these
mostly the sensory augmentation used in
combination and I would point to some
some research
that oh these are mostly case studies I
should be clear and not randomized
controlled studies or anything that a
journalist named Rachel newer has
pointed me to related to MDMA for social
anxiety and social cues
there are quite a number of people in
the communities the autism communities
who have experimented with sort of
durable effects on
social anxiety and social cues so I'll
stop there since there's plenty to pick
apart
but compelling surprising animal
communication within five years that
will then be propagandized by all the
political and special interests
it will become a very contentious area
so I'm not sure that it will have
uniformly positive impacts but that's my
prediction so one clarification the
psychedelics you were talking about
being applied to the humans not
necessarily to the animals no I think
that they can be applied to animals as
well in terms of reading body language
and becoming sort of opening the
reducing valve on sort of processing
that type of information particularly as
it relates to neuroplasticity and
adapting to sensory augmentation I think
that will be ultimately viewed as maybe
a very primitive approach to what the AI
can produce but I think they could all
work in tandem
I think you have nesting heresies there
because giving animals psychedelics is
the cell oh no not animals well I guess
animals human animals the Human animals
would be consuming that's what my
question was I was just talking about
giving the animals psychedelics although
I would like to fund research looking at
whether or not MDMA can help to reverse
the equivalent of PTSD and dogs who have
been abused yeah right I think that's
under explored but that's a whole
separate thing is the time frame of this
important for your heresy I just wanted
to kind of throw something out there
that would give people something
additional to object to
so you kind of created it you have your
hand up Noah I'm not gonna object but I
am really curious Tim about this and I
should begin by saying I know less than
nothing about this so when you talk
about communicating with animals I mean
first of all we already do a certain
amount of significant amount of
communicating with animals right and the
better you are say with dog at both
understanding where the dog is coming
from and communicating to it and what a
dog will understand and I've seen you do
the stem with your own dog really
beautifully you're having a much better
communicative relationship than a lot of
other people do with animals certainly
than I do it turns out Noah likes
listening to animals just doesn't like
listening to people there you go but
what I wanted to ask about the
communication Tim is like what are you
picturing because you know there's this
super famous
essay by the still going strong well
into his 80s philosopher Tom Nagel
called what is it like to be a bat and
you know basically what he tries to say
and if you're right this article will be
obsolete is that we can't really piece
together what it would be like to be a
bat from within our perspective and I
would think that maybe language is a
little bit like that so what would it
mean to hear you know to hear the animal
communicating I'm not talking about the
whale song here where it is enough like
language in that it has repetitive
patterns and it's sound and we can sort
of begin to picture the way it might be
used but what does it look like to you
to say we're understanding what the
animal is communicating to us is the AI
producing like a translation it's like
you know wolf GPT or something and it
like you know it just gives us a running
translate I mean just tell me what
you're talking about because I can't
really picture it sure so I think there
are multiple possibilities and I I do
not understand the technology if we're
talking about the AI side just
the the idea of calling that keeping it
simple is kind of hilarious in and of
itself but let's let's keep it simple
and talk about Ai and the sort of
computer science side of things I think
that for a communication model to be
functional and I say this is someone
who's studied a lot of human languages
first and foremost with say different
species we're talking about let's just
Define terms a little bit when I say
communication it could be human to
animal communication but it could also
and probably will first be animal to
animal communication so within a certain
species can you model the language in
such a way that there is a predictive
value does that make sense so you you
are able to predict what will happen
next based on pattern recognition
within a given species or even say it
could be a regional
iteration of a single species and we see
a lot of variants across say chimpanzees
depending on location but let me give an
example that Aza Raskin has brought up
just to give an example of of one of the
leads that I find interesting that I
think will develop over time so with
dolphins which also have this sort of
Sonic
patterning right so in in that sense as
a human it's a little easier to compare
these funny sounds coming out of my
mouth hole that are being molded by all
these muscles and so on
to a dolphin right
but with the dolphins you can ask a
dolphin and I don't know the exact
training that went into this
and we can come back to Nagel too and
the kind of behaviorism Skinner black
box type of stuff if you'd like
and I I don't think you need to
understand the internal functioning of
an animal to make progress with
communication in the same way that you
don't really understand what's going on
in any human's head but you infer that
based on what comes out so I do think
you could base it on observable data but
with the dolphin example that Aza is
given and I'm going to butcher this
because I'm I'm calling from memory but
these Marine Mammal trainers which is a
very interesting branch of animal
training for anyone who's interested in
say dog training it gets more
interesting when you get in the water
you can't hit a Miss bathing dolphin
with a rolled up newspaper not that I
would recommend that with a dog but they
will ask a dolphin to do something novel
so in other words do something you have
never done before and they have
confidence that this is being sort of
semantically communicated well enough
that the dolphin understands it is that
true or not who knows but they are able
to produce novel behaviors
the more interesting aspect to me
although I think that's very interesting
if you dig into it is that they can then
take two dolphins and say together do
something that you have never done
before and they like like would do
whatever they do and they confer and
then they simultaneously perform a novel
movement that they have never
demonstrated before
so I think a lot of it will be starting
with
trying to model
some type of predictive value on
language inputs using technology I think
that's where it's going to start where
it leads I honestly couldn't tell you
but I do think at some point we will be
able to produce we already can on some
very very primitive level bird song and
so on that have say alarm call values
right it's very rough but I think the
Fidelity of that
with the type of data that can be
captured now with better technology not
just AI but just simple kind of
audio technology
I think we will get to a point where and
this could be abused and Aza would agree
with this where you could actually
propagate messages say through water to
dolphins to whales I think it'll be
easier to start with mammals versus say
reptiles although you can train
chickens and other things
which I think is is a good idea if
you're planning on having kids you
should have to train a chicken or a dog
first I think
but I'm not sure if that answers the
question but that's that's where I think
things are at least starting at the
moment there's an example of prototype
version of that with dogs using these
little buttons yeah the buttons where
you record
a word onto it that was used often with
kids who are having trouble with with
language
and the the ultimate was
the scale who was teaching her dog to
speak by having she had a plywood
set up where they had 34 she got up to
34 different words that the dog could
press the buttons for and say a sentence
and it was again remarkable like Coco it
was kind of like a sign language but it
was an audible sign language where the
dog was constructing fairly complicated
sentences about what it wanted to do or
want to go outside and see its friend
and all kinds of remarkable things just
using the recorded sound on one word per
button and up to 34 and they had kind of
Primitives so they can
they could actually construct a fairly
complicated sentence yeah and so that
would if you could imagine that be
transferring into some kind of audible
language that would make it another step
yeah let me ask you a question do you
think if you're right it's going to lead
to a quite transformational view on
animal rights and people's willingness
to consume animal products
I do think that's one possibility
and that's related to my comment on uh
sort of political division and how
that's going to fit into things
I do think for millions of people who
are maybe towards the midline let's just
say you have a Continuum just to because
I I want to sound like a smart guy so
I'm going to use this too
if you have a Continuum from let's just
say pure
vegetarian to or like herbivore
carnivore and you have like 100 pure 100
pure Never Gonna Change and as you move
towards the middle you get to you get
increasingly flexible I think for people
who are close to that midpoint or maybe
even within you know 20 points a lot of
folks will switch to probably more
plant-based food which I do not for the
record think is automatically healthier
but for moral reasons I think more
people will switch at the same time my
experience because I've been involved
with
all sorts of things that are kind of at
odds people don't
we could talk about it but the
conservation work that I have done
conservation is viewed in very
particular way I think in a very
exaggerated way in the U.S specifically
you don't run into this as much say in
South America in Colombia when they're
producing like qdgete Park and so on or
protecting it but in the U.S
there's a great piece in the New Yorker
I think it's something along the lines
of the wolf lady or the powerful story
of the wolf lady and it talks about Wolf
Conservation which is basically
considered the Middle East of
conservation and how politicized it is
so there are people who want to kill
wolves just because they view it as a
magnet for Liberal
overreach with conservation city folks
telling rural folks how to live
there's more to that of course and then
you have the opposite on the liberal
side and it turns into this battlefield
for ideology where
something like a wolf or a fill in the
blank animal is a simple it becomes a
symbol and so I do think that
it will flip a lot of people towards
different Behavior
and simultaneously it will become hyper
polarized and you'll have competing
researchers or computer scientists who
are taking completely opposite
interpretive stances
based on whatever their political or
ideological goals will be but I do think
it'll change Behavior absolutely I'm not
a vegetarian I happen to I actually you
know I hunt and consume elk and deer and
so on
so my personal choice has been to sort
of set parameters around it so that I
feel ethically comfortable with
consuming nutrient-dense meat but I do
think a lot of people will switch to a
more
plant-based or synthetic based diet
which is not automatically healthy but I
do think that we'll see that change
Maggie
yeah I was recently at a very strange
kind of conference about
the Confluence of a lot of the things
we're talking about today about
multi-species constitutionalism
and this idea of trying to and being
able to communicate with other animals
was the the majority of the focus of
this this meeting
I was there because
my assertion was that we're not you know
the dominant again I'm an anthropologist
right something about culture all the
time but the dominant kind of cultural
world view or as people in my field call
it ontology which is just like an
obfuscating word for no reason
it's like let's make things harder we'll
say Praxis instead of practice it's just
like all right thanks for making this
less reachable by normal humans but we
don't have it built into our world view
to deal with this eventuality in my
opinion and there are plenty of cultures
that do have it built in to their world
for you to deal with this and I would
say that most of those are relational
cultures right so you know I'm native
bringing it back around to that you know
you have this idea of a relational world
where there is a connection and
reciprocal responsibility between every
entity in the universe including between
an individual squirrel who eats your
trash or whatever I guess that's a
raccoon but
and yourself you that raccoon has a
responsibility to you and you have a
responsibility to that raccoon right and
it gives a baseline right having a
conception of how to deal with
animals in a way that respects them as
what they are rather than what we need
them to be to fit into how the mechanics
of our world currently work is going to
be necessary to deal with this
eventuality or else it's going to be a
disaster like you said at the beginning
of this it's like you know who's gonna
get The Lorax endorsement on their
presidential campaign and you know stuff
that's just let's Churn it through the
meat grinder we currently have I think
is the danger you know not to be too
punny yeah totally The Lorax great
invocation I want to say a few more
things so
this is also so far we've only been
talking about what we would consider
animals I actually think it's going to
get stranger and
fungi well plants in general I don't
think that we will find that
eating plants is quite as ethically
black and white the opposite of eating
animals and there's a piece that Michael
Pollan wrote called the intelligent
plant in the New Yorker in 2013 a lot
has happened since then and you have to
be careful I think just to point out the
obvious with anthropomorphizing all
things I think there's a there are lots
of risks there but there are some very
seemingly credible researchers who have
observed some very very strange
phenomena which make plants seem much
more sentient much more sensitive
much more let's let's let's just call it
alive then I think many people who eat
solely plants would like to believe so I
think that's also going to complicate
matters and I'll just I'll just point
out also and you can romanticize a lot
of older cultures and I think there's a
risk that you see a lot of that in
Austin it's kind of drives me nuts on
some level but for everything new is bad
and everything old is great and I'm like
I don't know if it's that simple however
there are many many cultures and I've
had most of the exposure in South
America and Central America although I
know it's certainly true in other places
where the the idea of communicating in
some fashion with animals and plants is
completely uncontroversial
which is not to say that therefore it is
true but I find it I do find it
interesting that they're over the span
of Millennia In some cultures has a
there there's a durable uncontroversial
belief it's kind of like Tuesday comes
after Monday yes you can communicate
with plants or with fill in the blank
species so don't call them old those are
still living cultures that exist today
what's the right way to put it long long
stonerness
there we go traditional traditional
traditional traditional so Noah no you
have something to add here yeah I wanted
to ask a heretical question about the
heresy so let's say you're right Tim
let's say the heresy is true
maybe it'll go the other way maybe
instead of are thinking that ethically
we can't eat something that we can talk
to
we go the way that most traditional
cultures have gone which is they're not
necessarily vegetarian just because they
think they can communicate with animals
nor I mean if you can be here with
plants too you can eat the plants maybe
it would have the opposite effect maybe
we would no longer think that the
capacity to be sentient and communicate
is the basis for deserving our ethical
consideration yeah and maybe at the
margin that would even be bad this is
the heretical thought maybe that would
even be bad for the way we treat each
other I mean right Drawing the Line at
humans is problematic in a whole bunch
of ways obviously but at least it's had
one really big benefit over the last few
hundred years which is it's gradually
allowed us to recognize that all humans
deserve equal rights no matter what
aspect of those folks practices or
culture yeah we don't or appearance we
don't like the one used to not be
that human right right yeah so the thing
about wrong line at humans is in a lot
of ways it's obviously naive right but
it has done a lot of good drawing the
line of humans in terms of our treating
other humans not equally because we
never we never get there but treat them
as humans and respecting their inherent
dignity so the radical question would be
what if everything you you said happened
Tim and it made us like worse I think
it's entirely possible is my my short
response I have more thoughts but we get
back into genocide in a big way
there's a heresy that that I would not
bring up here but I would just have to
add which is yeah cannibalism is okay
long pork
right you drop the line yeah we can eat
humans sure it's fine if they're dead so
unless there's something else to add to
Tim's I want to move on to the last one
because we have only 15 minutes at least
I have only 15 minutes to talk about so
I picked heresy that I thought would be
we can have a short discussion rather
than a complicated one so we can finish
in time
and mine is that I think that
human clones are fine we should have
human clones that there's nothing wrong
with human clones and that's right now
there's a kind of a taboo about making
human clones but they're perfectly fine
because we already have human clones
they're called twins
there's you know simultaneous
clones but we get all freaked out with
serial clones
and actually in fact if we did not have
twins and we suddenly invented twins
people would call them the devil they
would just say that's just insanely evil
if we had twins and that we didn't have
them naturally
so so I think that
it's perfectly fine just to have serial
twins rather than just simultaneous
twins
okay
but according to you Kevin we can eat
them right exactly and we can eat them
too
twin farming eat yourself.com in saying
that
the reason people are like weirded out
by cereal twins
site it gives into the psychology of the
person who wants to serialize themselves
more so than the actual cloning well you
don't have to actually serialize
yourself you can make twins of anything
you don't have to make a twin of
yourself you don't have to clone
yourself you can clone anything you
could clone your neighbors if you wanted
to um
right exactly so it's not just cloning
of yourself that you have to do okay so
you clone your kids so you have an air
and a spare and you just keep going yeah
and then they could marry someone who is
ill-suited so Kevin what would you like
to see happen then I mean you're making
an ethical statement that this is okay
instead of not okay right but what would
some use cases be you think there's
obviously many people who lose a child
or something who would like to restore
that hmm
bring them back so to speak
and so
I don't think that we should prohibit
that just basis on the fact that there
are clones
but Kevin can I ask a question about
that I mean what's the at a deep level I
understand that people have that
instinct but what's the advantage of
that relative to a like a non-cloned
because the new clone like identical
twins won't actually be the same person
exactly they might look alike for some
period but they're they won't be the
same person and so if you had let's say
you lost a child and chose to have
another child I think if someone said we
lost our child we decide to have another
child we've none of us would think what
a terrible ethical reaction we would
think oh that's very understandable we
wouldn't condemn it but that's because
they would be acknowledging that it
wasn't going to be the same person all
over again and even if they named if
they named the child the same thing we
might raise our eyebrows quietly amongst
ourselves saying gosh don't they want
this child to have its own identity but
we probably would let that go too after
all we don't get too upset when people
name their kids after themselves sure
you know we know that they don't really
mean that that's going to be their kids
going to be a mini me yeah so I I don't
know I guess what I'm wondering is
what's the added value there I
understand people have the Instinct but
I
why is it any better than just saying
just have another child if you feel that
way I think you're right I think there's
going to be a lot would be a lot of
self-correction that in the sense that
people would understand that clones are
very rarely possible to have an
identical thing and so there would be
less maybe demand for it but it'll be
another Choice another option and there
might be times when it worked out I just
don't think it should be a Prohibition
the reason why there's a Prohibition is
there's a fear that they're going to be
taking over that that there are our
lives would be full of clones and that
there'd be nothing but clones and so
where does the prohibition come from
what if it turns into one of these like
weird Gattaca Elite things where you
start cloning people you think are
really smart or you know Usain Bolt or
something and you create this like
weird Elite Class you know and I think
what they discovered was to Noah's point
is is that cloning is there's no
guarantee that you're going to get
necessarily what you think you're going
to get because of we know twins
themselves they vary between each other
and triplets likewise I think you see
often how something which is super well
intentioned can run afoul of what
actually is best for society so you take
the example of sperm donors and who are
trying to help families get pregnant or
single mothers conceive and then you end
up having these cases where there are
other doctors or individuals who
ultimately have 500 children out in the
world which is a deep deep disservice
obviously to those children because now
you need to get genetically tested when
you start dating someone to make sure
that you're not dating your half sibling
and that's like a pretty unappealing
thought so the idea that we would have a
massive number of clones out there all
of them have to figure out whether in
fact they're huge genetic let alone
psychological issues associated with it
because as they get older they're not
going to be able to self-identify as
clones
doesn't that worry you what do you mean
well because even identical twins
relatively rapidly don't always look
alike and so you're not immediately
going to be able to know who's your
sibling who's not
whether you're intermarrying and doing
all sorts of things so from a genetic
perspective it doesn't seem like a
particularly wise thing for the species
to have thousands and thousands of
people who have their identical genetic
code right so you're saying if as soon
as you have clones you have thousands of
millions of them no you don't
necessarily but just the way no one
assumed when you had the opportunity to
have sperm donors that you were going to
have some idiot who decided that he
wanted to have 500 children right so I
would say you might want to regulate
clones but that's very different than
prohibiting them are they prohibited
I don't know if it's a treaty but
there's an agreement a biologist that
they're not going to do human cloning
okay yeah I mean I think one of the
reasons for that worry is that the kind
of worry that well both of the worries
both Josh's worry and Maggie's worry
that we're worried about people you know
trying to make tweaks to the Clone and
then tweak the Clone so that they
develop the germline in new ways and
that has both risks and ethical side but
I wanted to ask just taking on your
court case
I think the best thing you could say on
the opposite side you almost have to say
this is there's something about human
reproduction that should include
recombination and the randomness that
comes out of that recombination because
we're not saying it's completely random
because we let people choose who they're
going to have kids with if we're able we
want to let people choose and so we're
letting people decide within some
boundary who they're going to mix their
genetic material with but there is some
unavoidable inescapable and I think most
people think good Randomness about what
happens when you combine two genomes and
I guess that question would be what do
we lose if we give that up and I think
what we lose at some basic level is the
beauty of human variation
you know I mean and the thing about
twins is that that's also a product of
the randomness of human variation
especially identical twins well not
really ifvs is there's a huge
preponderance but those aren't identical
twins
almost always for channel and I'm
talking about identical Choice yeah
exactly identical twins are themselves
that's a rare outlying random experience
so my argument would be that we
shouldn't as a society want to encourage
human reproduction
that it doesn't have that element of
Randomness because it encourages us to
believe that we can plan out in advance
what someone's going to look like and
from there
what their life is going to be like in
some way and it's already benefit I mean
I'm a parent of teenagers yeah I already
sorry I'll just close I'll shut up I
already have two I'm too invested
already in what my kids turn out like I
need to be every day I wake up and try
to be less invested in that and here it
just feels like an invitation to people
to be more invested well no just to your
point the societies that have tried this
most closely which are the royal
families of Europe is inevitably ended
badly the enormous Jaws huge health
issues because they were convinced yeah
they were convinced that the way to
ensure exactly what Noah described was
to intermarry and the result was
insanity and deep deep physical
deformity so any experiments that we've
seen in real life have not ended well
right to the extent that there are
problems and it wouldn't work I think
those are going to be self-correcting
you would say okay
we don't want to do this or trying to
engineer this always have trade-offs and
whatever we could going to try to
eliminate this disease Parkinson's
Alzheimer's there is inevitably going to
be some trade-off If you eliminate that
kind of a gene from your clone and so
Eugenics we're drifting into Eugenics
and and that's the concern is that this
turns into a form of eugenics but it
doesn't have to
again I think we want to have the option
of it we don't want to close off the
option we want to be able to manage it
and do it just like you know we don't
prohibit twins would you allow people to
sell their genetic material so you see
some person who's super successful and
she decides you know what
if you want to have someone like me I've
been super successful
I'll sell you a clone of me and so
couples are deciding right that they go
off and want to have Maggie as their
daughter would you allow her to do that
that's a decision people do buy and sell
eggs right I mean for surrogate babies
and and I don't know if sperm is
actually sold or not you can sell it I'm
not sure you have to buy it
I want to say as like a kind of related
sidebar as someone who is currently
gestating and pretty far along I would
like to say it all sucks and we
shouldn't do any of it yeah that's all
just a personal company so Maggie if you
could do it in the lab you would is what
you're saying yeah oh man like in The
Matrix where there's like some other
like spider thing yeah this sucks
so Kevin I just want to say since I'm
your friend and I care for you yeah for
your next cannibal Buffet you should
also pay attention to genetic diversity
so you don't get kudu it's just the
Laughing death it would hurt my soul to
see you die don't eat the brains yeah
yeah donate your brains well this is so
it's really been great everybody here I
hope Tim that you found it successful
and we'd do it another version someday
and I appreciate everybody being willing
to to play along with the game the
unwritten rules I liked it exactly yeah
so fun and I'll just say to people
listening we will put links to whatever
we mentioned that can be linked to we
will include links and also to everyone
who's been on the show in the show notes
as always at tim.blog podcast but this
was a great experiment
I really enjoyed it it really was it was
a lot of fun so thank you guys thank you
Kevin for coming in with the sage
experience yeah for our maiden voyage
and I think fondly back to the night
when I first experienced this in our
small group doing doing our Walkabout it
was really great a lot of fun thanks for
making the time everybody yeah really
really appreciate for having me